200 Milliarden gegen die winterangst
gegen die Energiekrise denn die Lage ist
aktuell sehr ernst
wir befinden uns in einem energiekrieg
um Wohlstand und Freiheit dieser
energiekrieg hat zum Ziel
vieles von dem zu zerstören was die
Menschen sich persönlich über Jahrzehnte
aufgebaut haben was über Jahrzehnte an
Strukturen in Mittelstand Handwerk und
Industrie aufgebaut worden ist wir
können das nicht akzeptieren und werden
uns zur Wehr setzen deutliche Worte von
Christian Lindner auf der
Pressekonferenz im Grenzland für den
deutschen Finanzminister ist klar
Russland führt nicht nur Krieg gegen die
Ukraine sondern auch gegen uns die
Angriffe auf die Gaspipelines in der
Ostsee machen unmissverständlich klar
auch wir befinden uns im Krieg wir sind
mitten in einem energiekrieg den
Russland gegen uns führt mit allen
Mitteln nach der Sabotage von noch
unbekannter Hand in der Ostsee hat sich
die Lage weiter ver wir können jetzt
nicht mehr davon ausgehen Gas aus
Russland zu beziehen deswegen schnürt
die Regierung ein weiteres gigantisches
Entlastungspaket einen Abwehrschirm um
die Preisexplosionen von Strom und Gas
aufzuhalten 200 Milliarden Euro schwer
der doppelwumms und die gasumlage sie
ist Geschichte dafür kommen jetzt zwei
neue Waffen die strompreisbremse und die
gaspreisbremse der Kanzler weiß die
Preise müssen sinken damit Familien
Handwerksbetriebe und Industrie
überleben können dafür wird die
Bundesregierung alles tun
damit die Preise sinken spannen wir
jetzt einen großen Abwehrschirm ein
Abwehrschirm der dazu beitragen soll
dass die Rentner und Rentner in unserem
Land das die Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmer die Familien auf dem Lande
und in der Stadt dass die Singles des
die Verkäuferinnen und Verkäufer das
alle gut zurechtkommen können und dass
sie die Preise bezahlen können auch die
hohen Rechnungen die einige jetzt
bereits bekommen haben als
Abschlagszahlung wenn sich dann wieder
reduzieren können das ist das konkrete
ziel der Maßnahme und der Förderung die
wir uns vorgenommen haben wir befinden
uns in einem energiekrieg um Wohlstand
und Freiheit zum ersten Mal spricht die
Politik von Krieg nicht nur den Krieg in
der Ukraine auch einen gegen uns und
dieser Krieg ist noch längst nicht
gewonnen
es ist eine Zahl die schockt 10%
Inflation die Preise kennen keinen
Halten mehr kennen tatsächlich nur noch
einen Weg und der geht immer wieder
steil nach oben im September war das
Leben zehn Prozent teurer als noch
letztes Jahr 10 Prozent das gab es seit
fast 70 Jahren nicht mehr der teuer
Schock bremst zugleich auch die
Konjunktur fürs nächste Jahr fürchten
die Institute dass die
Wirtschaftsleistung um 0,4% schrumpft im
schlimmsten Fall könnte sie sogar um
7,9% einbrechen und das wäre dann
ebenfalls Rekord wir wollten von Ihnen
wissen ob sie sich Sorgen machen Sorgen
vor diesen kalten Winter sorgen also vor
der Zukunft
das sind immer größere Herausforderungen
und die Fragen werden immer mehr und die
Antworten immer weniger von daher ist ja
ist da einiges zu tun also sorry dreimal
so früh für mein Gas oder für meinen
Strom oder soll ich sechs Mal so viel
und also
ja und das macht einen unzufrieden
aktuell die steigenden Preise man merkt
es auch wirklich an den Gaspreise machen
wenn der Abschlagszahlungen die halt
drastisch erhöht werden es wird halt
immer teurer und teurer und wir wissen
nicht wie wie wir aus auskommen
sozusagen einfach ob irgendwie mit Atom
etwas kommt dass meine Hauptsache ja ein
bisschen schon aber im Moment geht's
noch ganz normal 14 Cent gewesen dieser
Strom mehr kostet bei zu Hause es geht
noch so
ich habe Angst dass wir es nicht
schaffen und dass wir einen gewaltigen
demonstrationsdruck darauf hinbekommen
Angst ist sowas typisch deutsches gehen
Sie mal ins Ausland sagen wir
vergleichen Sie mal Deutschland mit
England
wenn ich in England wäre da würde ich
Angst bekommen und Zuständen in die
gesamte politische Situation dazu gehört
natürlich auch der Ukraine Krieg wo sich
die Menschen Gedanken machen inwiefern
sich das eventuell sogar noch ausweitet
ja das wäre ein ganz großes Problem ja
welche weltpolitische Lage wegen der
steigen Inflation man weiß nicht wo es
hingeht viele Leute können Ihre Rechnung
nicht mehr bezahlen
die Schere zwischen armen reich wird
aufgehen wenn man irgendwie alleine
wohnt dann ist es schon problematisch so
ein Privatleben schon also gerade auch
im einkaufen und alles das Leben ist
viel teurer geworden
also das spürt man schon es macht einem
Angst das macht einem Angst ja
die Menschen haben also Angst 200
Milliarden Euro dieses Entlastungspaket
und so teuer kommt uns die
energiepreisbremse damit zu stehen wir
alle bezahlen diesen Preis auch für
jahrelange politische Naivität es ist
dieses Foto das zeigt die Regierung
damals führte uns in die Abhängigkeit
Putins exkanzlerin Angela Merkel bei der
feierlichen Eröffnung der Ostseepipeline
Nord Stream mit dabei damals Altkanzler
und putinfreund Gerhard Schröder und
auch ex-stasi-agent und Nord Stream
Geschäftsführer Matthias warning heute
zahlen wir den Preis dafür wie gesagt
200 Milliarden Euro
einen doppelwurms wie ihn Kanzler Scholz
nennt und zu diesem Thema begrüßen wir
den stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion zuständig für
Energiewirtschaft Klima und Mittelstand
und damit ist er der Gegenspieler von
Robert Habeck schönen guten Morgen Jens
Spahn schönen guten Morgen hallo 200
Milliarden Euro das ist der Preis der
Politik der letzten 16 Jahre der Politik
von Frau Merkel und auch der Politik der
Union wer ist an der Zeit sich zu
entschuldigen nun das ist mir etwas zu
kurz gesprungen es ist der Preis den wir
alle dafür zahlen dass wir vorher von
günstiger russischer Energie auch
gemeinsam gut gelebt haben bis zur
pandemiebeginn gab es fast zehn Jahre
wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung und der war
sehr stark auch getriggert durch
günstige Energieversorgung also ja aus
heutiger Sicht würde man manche
Entscheidungen an das Treffen es war
falsch und eine so starke Abhängigkeit
von Russland zu kommen aber zum
Gesamtbild gehört eben auch dazu wir
haben auch alle profitiert von diesem
günstigen russischen Spaß die deutsche
Industrie war deswegen wettbewerbsfähig
Arbeitsplätze sind entstanden im
Nachhinein hätte man manche
Entscheidungen anders treffen müssen
übrigens nicht nur wir auch wir müssen
unseren Teil aufarbeiten nicht nur die
Union aber es gibt kein Grund sich zu
entschuldigen sagen Sie es gibt Grund
was aufzuarbeiten das absolut wie konnte
es eigentlich passieren dass ich meine
wir haben 50 Prozent des Gases aus
Russland bezogen wie konnte es passieren
dass wir so stark in einer Abhängigkeit
von einem einzelnen Land kommen das dann
ja auch kein demokratischer Partner ist
sondern eine autokratur und das darf nie
wieder passieren und deswegen müssen wir
ganz anders Risikoanalysen machen
übrigens wir als Bund als Politik aber
auch die Unternehmen dass man wirklich
mal die Szenarien durchspielt das
sollten wir etwa mit Blick auf China und
Taiwan jetzt auch dringend tun der
Bundeskanzler spricht gestern bei der
gaspreisbremse von einem doppelwumms
sagt es muss keine Angst haben wenn er
an Weihnachten oder ans nächste Jahr
denkt können wir uns tatsächlich
entspannen
wissen sie das Problem ist ja das ist
der Kanzler der markigen Worte
Zeitenwende doppelwumms Bazooka das sind
alles Begriffe die er geprägt hat nur
leider ist meistens am Tag danach die
Flughöhe schon nicht mehr gehalten also
ich will jetzt einfach mal konkret sehen
was denn passieren sollen und hat mit
den 200 Milliarden sozusagen die
Munition bereitgelegt aber wir wissen
überhaupt noch gar nicht wie auf welches
Ziel in schwarze geschossen werden soll
um mal in diesem Bild zu bleiben es ist
also noch wenig ein Details da und das
ist ja das Problem der letzten Monate im
auch dieser Krise es wird viel
angekündigt markige Worte beeindruckende
Zahlen das Ziel ist ja auch richtig die
Preise müssen gerade für die mit
geringerem Einkommen und für Handwerk
und Industrie runter damit wir durch
diesen Winter kommen aber wir müssen es
ja auch mal schauen was ist konkret
gemeint und wie sollen wir durch diesen
Winter kommen was raten Sie zum Beispiel
einer mittelständischen Familie soll sie
schon den Urlaub fürs nächste Jahr
buchen soll sie das machen oder soll sie
eben gucken wo sie sparen kann auch
vielleicht mit dem Blick schon auf die
Weihnachtsgeschenke was ist ihr Spartipp
also erstmal halte ich nichts von
dusch-tipps oder waschlappentipps mein
Eindruck ist dass die allermeisten
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und auch
Unternehmen wegen der hohen Preise von
sich aus schon schauen wo sie sparen
können ich finde da sollte sich Politik
zurückhalten die Preise setzen ihr
Signal wichtig ist eines und das ist ja
auch gerade bei den Stimmen aus den
Städten die sie eingespielt haben
deutlich geworden viele Bürgerinnen und
Bürger brauchen ein Stück
Planungssicherheit wir gehen gerade in
die Heizperiode die startet offiziell am
1.10 ich glaube viele haben die Heizung
schon hochgedreht die letzten kälteren
Tage und keiner weiß aber wie teuer wird
jetzt das Heizen für mich was genau ist
der Preis mit dem ich irgendwie
kalkulieren kann und deswegen ist dieser
gasgrundbedarf der ja jetzt kommen soll
ich meine wir diskutieren in seit sechs
Monaten der ist so wichtig dass man zum
Beispiel sagt 75% des
vorjahresverbrauches zu maximal 12 Cent
man kann an den Summen arbeiten dabei
kann jeder mit dem Taschenrechner
ausrechnen das kostet mich das in diesem
Winter zu heizen und trotzdem wird es
teurer sein als letztes Jahr also sparen
macht in jedem Fall Sinn aber ich bin
sicher dass überlegt jeder für sich
selbst da braucht er keine Tipps von mir
was wäre denn hier ihr genauer Vorschlag
bei dem gasgrundbedarf ja unser
Vorschlag ist ja tatsächlich diese 75
Prozent Jahres Vorjahresverbrauch zu
maximal 12 Cent das ist höher als es
bisher war es ist teurer aber es ist
eben sozusagen ein ein Deckel drin wo
auch jeder weiß das wird mich nicht
überfordern das ist eben das mit dem ich
planen kann und diese Debatte über den
gasgrundbedarf den gibt es seit März
also ist ja richtig dass die Regierung
jetzt sagt die Preise müssen runter für
Familien für Handwerk für die Bäcker nur
die Debatte ist ja nicht neu also es
wird jetzt so nach dem erkenntnispreise
müssen runter das wussten wir eigentlich
schon seit Monaten wenn es jetzt
passiert ist es gut aber das muss jetzt
eben auch sitzen also nach der
Ankündigung muss das jetzt auch sitzen
sonst geht Vertrauen verloren und wir
spüren ja auf der Straße wir spüren in
den Gesprächen diese Unsicherheit führt
auch zu sozialen Unfrieden und diese
Regierung hat jetzt eine Verantwortung
nach dieser Ankündigung jetzt auch
tatsächlich zu liefern die Frage ist
natürlich wann der gaspreisdeckel denn
tatsächlich kommt Friedrich Merz hat von
einem komplizierten
Gesetzgebungsverfahren gesprochen und
die Menschen warten natürlich darauf
dass die Preise runtergehen aber tritt
dieser gaspreisdeckel noch dieses Jahr
in Kraft was glauben Sie es wäre sehr zu
wünschen dass er schnell in Kraft tritt
das schnell Planungssicherheit sich
ergibt für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
für die Unternehmen
ich muss jetzt warten auf den konkreten
Vorschlag der Region ist ein bisschen
das Problem ich bin noch etwas
verwundert über diese Pressekonferenz
gestern also man stellt die Summe schon
mal ein Schaufenster 200 Milliarden
markige Worte aber keiner weiß was genau
eigentlich jetzt passiert und diese
Salami Taktik in der Kommunikation das
ist schon irgendwie was besonderes an
dieser Regierung ist aber erkennen
Energie genauso also er ist gar nicht
dann irgendwie zwei ein bisschen dann
zwei also es ist so diese Salami Taktik
schafft viel Verunsicherung übrigens
kennen Energie da würde ich mir ein
dreifach Wumms wünschen dass nämlich
alle drei Kernkraftwerke gerade auch das
in Niedersachsen das ist nämlich das
neueste modernste tatsächlich die
nächsten zwei Winter weiterlaufen also
nicht nur
bis Absagen die nächsten zwei Winter
bevor wir sozial entlasten was richtig
ist wer noch wichtiger das Angebot
auszuweiten wir haben einen Strom ein
Energiemangel deswegen ist der Preis so
hoch es muss alles ans Netz und am Netz
bleiben das gilt für Kohlekraftwerke das
gilt aber vor allem auch für
Kernkraftwerke deswegen ja mindestens
bis Ende 2024 sollten alle drei
Kernkraftwerke durchgängig laufen dass
das modernste wie gesagt den Lingen in
Niedersachsen nur weil Wahlkampf in
Niedersachsen ist nur weil Jürgen
Trittin um sein Lebenswerk fürchtet
springen die Grünen da nicht über ihren
parteipolitischen Schatten und das ist
ein Problem für Deutschland also wenn
jetzt schon Wumms Zeit ist um den
Kanzler zu zitieren mit seinen markigen
Worten dann bitte auch bei der
Kernenergie Minister Habeck sagt dass in
vielen Teilen der Wirtschaft bereits die
Hütte brennt reichen all diese Maßnahmen
jetzt ihrer Meinung nach aus
das liegt jetzt sehr daran wie sie
ausgestaltet werden weil all diese
Maßnahmen mehr bis jetzt noch nicht
auspusht statt wird ist also wir wissen
200 Milliarden ist die Summe die jetzt
erstmal angekündigt worden ist aber viel
wichtiger finde ich jenseits der Summe
wo wir auch schauen müssen die wissen
das eigentlich finanziert auch der Teil
ist ja noch nicht so richtig beantwortet
was ist wie zielgerichtet also
gasgrundbedarf scheint ja die Richtung
zu sein das was ich gerade skizziert
habe für die privaten Haushalte wenn das
so kommt gibt das Sicherheit ist auch
unser Vorschlag werden wir das
konstruktiv unterstützen was wir
brauchen für Bäckerhandwerk Mittelstand
energieintensive Industrie ist eben auch
eine Planbarkeit und vor allem
Liquiditätshilfe sie haben ja alle
funktionierende Geschäftsmodelle also
der Bäcker hat ja eigentlich ein
Geschäftsmodell das funktioniert hat
Kunden hat ein gutes Produkt vielfach
und das gilt für den mittelständischen
kunststoffbetrieb genauso sie haben nur
ein Liquiditätsproblem ein riesiges
gerade wegen der hohen Energiepreise und
da muss man gezielt ansetzen ob das so
kommt oder nicht kann ich leider heute
morgen noch nicht beantworten welcher
Teil der ist der die den ist die
Regierung noch schuldig aber gibt dieses
Paket denn die Sicherheit wenn wir
einmal zurückschauen während der
Finanzkrise haben Merkel und Steinbrück
gesagt das war 2008 das Geld der Sparer
ist sicher und das hatte ein
psychologischen Effekt der sich
ausgewirkt hat auf die Bürger ist das in
dieser Krise ebenfalls möglich
es ist wahrscheinlich schon möglich wenn
man das geschlossen und einheitlich
macht und wenn man es rechtzeitig macht
also das Problem es ist das ich bin ich
bin da selbst gerade noch sie merken ich
überlege gerade weil ich mich auch frage
wie wirkt das jetzt gerade wieder so
halb halt ne 200 Milliarden aber keiner
weiß genau wofür was bringt das
Sicherheit bringt das Ruhe in die
Debatten ich bin mir noch nicht sicher
dass das wirklich sozusagen so geeint
und so so in sich schlüssig ist dass das
tatsächlich die vielen Sorgen die wir
gerade gehört haben auch beruhigt das
muss man ja sagen das ist ein Angela
Merkel per Steinbrück damals gelungen
eben eine Sicherheit zu vermitteln auch
zu geben dass danach auch eben nicht die
Leute zur Bank gerannt sind und ihr Geld
abgehoben haben das war ja das was
gedroht hat sondern auch ruhig und mit
einem Vertrauen in die Regierung in
diese Krise gegangen sind und nachdem
jetzt der Finanz und der
Wirtschaftsminister sechs Monate lang
jeden Tag Schuldenbremse Kernenergie
gasumlage gestritten haben ist natürlich
das was nötig ist und vertrauen gut zu
gewinnen wahrscheinlich ein etwas
längerer Weg als die eine
Pressekonferenz gestern aber die Drohung
von Blackouts die steht nun mal im Raum
faltet wird das Produkt
ions werden müssen das Unternehmen nicht
mehr weiter produzieren können weil die
Energie einfach nicht ausreicht das ist
eine Risiko das es gibt das zeigt ja
auch der Stresstest der gemacht worden
ist und dieser Stresstest empfiehlt eben
zum Beispiel dass alle drei
Kernkraftwerke mindestens mal im
streckbetrieb aber der nächste Winter
übrigens also der übernächste wird noch
schwieriger werden und aus heutiger
Sicht als dieser Winter dass man das
Angebot ausweitet also das ist eben
bevor es die richtigen
Entlastungsmaßnahmen gibt ist der erste
viel wichtigere Schritt alles was in
diesem Land Strom Energie produzieren
kann muss ans Netz damit das Risiko etwa
von Blackouts oder brown-outs nennt man
ja das gezielte abschalten für
möglicherweise auch regional der
Stresstest schließt das nicht aus und um
das zu reduzieren das Risiko muss alles
ans Netz was geht sonst sind das
tatsächlich die Blackouts dieser
Regierung wir sehen gerade auch Bilder
der beiden nordstream Pipelines 1 und 2
wie beunruhigend finden Sie die
Anschläge auf diese beiden Pipelines
weil es kann uns ja niemand garantieren
dass nicht noch weitere Anschläge jetzt
folgen werden
finde das sehr beunruhigend es ist 150
Kilometer ja auch vor der deutschen
Küste Schweden Dänemark nah das ist das
erste Mal in diesem Konflikt in diesem
Krieg und dass diese Anschläge verbunden
sind kausal mit dem Krieg das glaube ich
bezweifelt niemand das erste Mal dass
nicht auf dem GBW Russlands oder der
Ukraine ist zu einem kriegerischen
gewaltsam terroristischen Akt kommt es
ist noch nicht klar wer es war die
Ostsee Putin war's ich halte mich da
zurück mit Spekulationen die Ostsee
dürfte mit zu dem best ausgeleuchtesten
seeräumen der Welt gehören deswegen bin
ich sehr sicher wird man das auch
aufklären können aber es ist erstmal
macht das sehr kleine Verwundbarkeit die
wir haben als Deutschland als
Europäische Union bei unserer
Energieversorgung bei der
Telekommunikation viele Kabel auch unter
der Erde und vieles was wir für
selbstverständlich gehalten haben das
hat die war in der Pandemie so das ist
jetzt in dieser Krise so das ist eben
nicht voraussetzungsfrei und da sind wir
Stellen sehr verwundbar und das spüren
wir etwa auch bei einem solchen Anschlag
sie haben die Pandemie gerade
angesprochen haben sie dieses Gerät hier
eine Frage die sind dieses Gerät wissen
Sie was das ist wahrscheinlich ein
raumlüfter oder ein Luftfilter ganz
viele Schulen in Deutschland haben solch
einen Luftfilter aufgebaut drei Jahre
nach Beginn der Pandemie wie würden Sie
jetzt reagieren in diesem Winter in den
Schulen würden sie ihn anmachen wegen
Corona oder würden sie ihn auslassen
wegen der Energiekrise
das ist eine Frage vor der ja gerade bei
vielen anderen Themen bis hin zum
Heizlüfter auch viele viele stehen ich
würde das sehr abhängig machen auch
einfach vom Infektionsgeschehen das ist
regional gibt das ist ja eine Lehre
gerade auch aus den letzten Monaten und
das ist ja auch eine Möglichkeit die wir
jetzt haben anders als vor zwei Jahren
regional auf Infektionsgeschehen zu zu
reagieren insofern wurde Inzidenz
niedrig ist kann man wahrscheinlich auch
mal auf den raumlüfter verzichten aber
auch da ist das das zeigt einfach gerade
wir haben mehrere Krisen parallel weil
sie fragen ja Strom sparen oder
raumlüften wegen der Viren ja immer
empfohlen wir haben als eine mögliche
time-maßnahme ja wir haben mehrere
Krisen parallel und die setzen gerade
uns die setzen die Gesellschaft die
setzen jede Familie gerade ziemlich
unter Stress und da komme ich zu dem
eigentlichen Punkt zurück den ich dem
wichtigsten finde es braucht eine
Regierung die vertrauen die
Verlässlichkeit vermittelt das haben wir
die letzten sechs Monate nicht gesehen
wenn das gestern der Startpunkt dafür
sein sollte dass das jetzt endlich
passiert dann werden wir auch solche
Fragen lösen können erwarten Sie im her
BST noch kommen müssen
was denken sehen Sie es mir nach ich
habe mir vorgenommen als ehemaliger
Minister der zuständig war aktuelle
tagesaktuelle corona-politik nicht zu
kommentieren und das werde ich auch
sogar hier bei Ihnen heute morgen
weiterhin so beibehalten herzlichen Dank
für das
Gespräch
[Musik]